in the last episode we learned about tfx
which helps us engineer our machine
learning pipeline so we can deploy our
models
in production are you ready to see it
all in action
let's go
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning
i'm priyanka rogaria and today i'm going
to show you how to manage a production
machine learning pipeline using tfx for
this we are going to use the chicago
taxi data set
available in bigquery and the goal of
our model is to predict if customers tip
more
or less than 20 so it is a binary
classification problem
here's what we will do first we will set
up our environment on google cloud
then we'll set up and deploy ai
pipelines on a kubernetes cluster
using kubeflow then we set up cloud ai
platform notebook instance
and work in the notebook to run the
pipeline
we hop into the google cloud console and
create an ai platform pipeline cluster
configure the kubeflow pipeline make
sure to allow
access to the cloud apis this is an
important step for the cluster to access
other pieces of our project once the
cluster is created
we deploy the pipeline now we open
our pipeline dashboard and the tf
notebook
we create a new notebook instance here
you can change the machine type here to
a faster processing machine
but remember that there's a cost
associated with your choice
now we are in our notebook the first
step
is to install tfx and qfloor pipeline
packages
downloading scaffold module we then set
the path to include
user python binary directory and a
directory containing scaffold
then we check which version of tfx is
installed
and then set the project id as the
environment variable
set the kubeflow cluster endpoint and
then we set the name
for the custom docker image of our
pipeline and now we set the name of
our pipeline and copy the pipeline
template into the project directory
today for this example we're using
chicago taxi data set to perform binary
classification
so the template sets the model to taxi
as a result of this command
in the file browser we see a basic
scaffold of files that build a pipeline
including python source codes sample
data
and jupyter notebooks now if you're
working on a different problem these
files might look a little bit different
here let's see what these files are
pipeline directory contains the
definition of the pipeline
config.py defines the common constants
for the pipeline runners
pipeline.py defines the tfx components
and a pipeline models directory contains
the machine learning model definitions
features.py and features test.py defines
the
features of the model preprocessing.py
and preprocessing test
file defines feature engineering using
tfx transform
estimator directory contains an
estimator-based model
inside that constants.pui defines
constants of the model
and model.py and model test.py defines
the dnn model
using the tensorflow estimator keras
directory contains a keras-based model
which is
constants.py file defines the constants
of the model
and the model.py and modeltest.py
defines the dnn model
using cares cubeflow dag runner file
defines runners for each orchestration
engine
this example includes both an estimator
based model
and a case model for reference so you
should choose whichever one is best for
you
now before we run our tfx pipeline on
kubeflow we first need
somewhere to store the artifacts that
will be created when we run the pipeline
these artefacts are called payloads and
we will use google cloud storage to
store them
we copy our sample data to gcs and then
we create the pipeline
this will generate a docker file and
build.yaml
to build a docker image make sure to add
these files to your source code system
for example git
along with other source files now we are
ready to run
our tfx pipeline using the tfx run
create command
we can also see this run under
experiments in the kubeflow pipelines
dashboard
now the first task in any data science
or machine learning project is to
understand
and clean the data example gen ingests
and splits the input data set
statistics gin calculates statistics for
the data set
schema gen examines the statistics and
creates a data schema
example validator looks for the
anomalies and missing values inside the
data set
in the pipeline dot py file we will
enable these components and
update the pipeline for a rerun after
the rerun we can see our pipeline in the
visual format
and after understanding the data and
cleaning it the next step
is to transform to increase the
predictive quality of our data and
reduce the dimensionality
and feature engineering after
transforming the data
we use the trainer component of the tfx
to train our model
then we would run evaluator to perform
deep analysis of the training results
and then we use the pusher component
to deploy the model to a serving
infrastructure
i enabled all these in the pipeline.py
and the resulting pipeline with all the
components
looks like this in the kubeflow
dashboard depending on the requirements
of your workload your pipeline might
need more cpus
gpus or memory to modify these i've
included the documentation below
now that we know how the tfx pipeline
works
you might be wondering how we can
directly use bigquery as the data source
there's a component called bigquery
example gen that connects to bigquery in
a specified google cloud project
tfx interoperates with several other
managed google cloud services such as
cloud data flow
several tfx components use apache beam
to implement
data parallel pipelines and it means
that you can distribute data processing
workloads
using cloud dataflow tfx also
interoperates with cloud ai platform for
training and prediction
you can set your trainer component to
use cloud ai platform training
which is a managed service for training
machine learning models
and when your model is built and ready
to be served
you can push your model to cloud ai
platform prediction for survey
in this video we just created and ran a
machine learning pipeline and visualized
the results of
each run give dfx a try yourself with a
different data set
and let me know how it goes in the
comments below if you like this video
and would like to see more such content
give us a like and subscribe
you